>> Larry: BRING UP THE LIGHTS!
BRING IT UP!
THANK YOU!
THANK YOU VERY MUCH!
CALM DOWN!
THANK YOU, THANK YOU!
I AM SO EXCITED TO BE HERE.
MAN, SO EXCITING.
I FEEL LIKE THERE'S SO MUCH TO
TALK ABOUT.
ESPECIALLY IF I HAD THE SHOW A
YEAR AGO!
(LAUGHTER)
ALL OF THE GOOD BAD RACE STUFF
HAPPENED ALREADY!
THERE'S NONE LEFT.
WE'RE DONE.
HAPPY M.L.K. DAY, EVERYBODY!
ACTUALLY, WAIT, THERE'S A 2015
INJUSTICE THAT'S BUGGING ME.
I'M TALKING, OF COURSE, ABOUT
THE OSCAR NOMINATIONS.
OR LACK THEREOF.
A VERY POWERFUL MOTION PICTURE
WAS SNUBBED.
THIS FILM'S MESSAGE IS AS
POIGNANT TODAY AS IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN WHEN I WAS A KID.
("EVERYTHING IS AWESOME" SONG
FROM THE LEGO MOVIE)
♪ EVERYTHING IS AWESOME ♪
♪ EVERYTHING IS COOL WHEN YOU'RE
PART OF A TEAM ♪
♪ EVERYTHING IS AWESOME! ♪♪
>> Larry: NO, EVERYTHING IS
NOT AWESOME!
HOW DID THE LEGO MOVIE NOT GET
NOMINATED FOR BEST PICTURE?
GOD, THIS WAS SHOCKING!
IN LESS SHOCKING NEWS, THIS ALSO
HAPPENED.
>> WHILE THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVIE
"SELMA" EARNED A BEST PICTURE
NOMINATION, DIRECTOR AVA
DUVERNAY WAS SNUBBED.
>> SO WAS LEAD ACTOR DAVID
OYELOWO.
>> Larry: OH, BLACK PEOPLE
DIDN'T GET NOMINATED FOR AN
OSCAR?
YEAH, I'M MAD, I GUESS.
DON'T GET ME WRONG.
AVA DUVERNAY SHOULD DEFINITELY
HAVE BEEN NOMINATED FOR BEST
DIRECTOR.
BUT DAVID OYELOWO?
HE'S A BRITISH BROTHER. I DON'T
REALLY CARE ABOUT THEM
SO WHAT DO WE AS A PEOPLE NEED
TO DO?
I WISH THERE WERE A BLACK
HOLLYWOOD EXPERT WHO COULD GO TO
BAT FOR US.
>> REVEREND SHARPTON CALLED FOR
AN EMERGENCY MEETING HERE IN
HOLLYWOOD NEXT WEEK TO DISCUSS
POSSIBLE ACTION AROUND THE
ACADEMY AWARDS.
>> Larry: SHARPTON?
AGAIN?
NO ONE ELSE CAN REPRESENT US?
LOOK, AL, SLOW DOWN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO RESPOND TO
EVERY BLACK EMERGENCY.
YOU'RE NOT BLACK BATMAN OR OUR
RACIAL FIRE CHIEF.
I'M BEGINNING TO THINK A TYPICAL
DAY AT AL SHARPTON'S OFFICE
LOOKS LIKE THIS.
>> THANK YOU.
WE GOT ONE!
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: TRUE.
TRUE.
LOOK AT YOURSELF, AL SHARPTON.
I APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS, PUT
YOU'RE LITERALLY STRETCHING
YOURSELF THIN.
TAKE A BREAK, MAN.
SERIOUSLY.
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT YOU.
AL,
YOU NEED TO EAT FOOD.
NOT JUST AIR TIME.
OKAY.
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS JUST
DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT.
ARE WE PROTESTING TOO MANY
THINGS HERE?
SINCE IT'S M.L.K. DAY, AND SINCE
HE'S THE PATRON SAINT OF
NON-VIOLENT PROTESTERS -- SUCK
IT, GANDHI!  --
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
STATE OF THE BLACK PROTEST.
AND THERE WERE A LOT OF THEM
THIS YEAR.
THERE WAS THE FERGUSON PROTEST,
THE GARNER PROTEST, AND THEN THE
NYPD PROTEST OF THE HANDLING OF
THAT PROTEST.
THEN THERE WAS A BLACK BRUNCH
PROTEST.
YESTERDAY IN OAKLAND, PEOPLE
WERE PROTESTING POLICE VIOLENCE.
AND EVEN AS I SPEAK TONIGHT,
THERE'S A DEMONSTRATION GOING ON
IN GRAND CENTRAL STATION,
BECAUSE THERE'S NO BETTER WAY TO
WIN THE HEARTS AND MINDS OF
WHITE PEOPLE THAN MAKING THEM
MISS THEIR TRAIN TO CONNECTICUT.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: IT'S TRUE!
THEY HATE THAT (BLEEP)!
(LAUGHTER)
NO, I GET IT.
SOME PEOPLE ARE DISCOURAGED.
THEY THINK PROTESTS DON'T WORK
ANYMORE.
BUT PROTESTS CAN WORK.
LET ME GIVE YOU A FEW EXAMPLES.
400,000 PEOPLE MARCHED IN
NEW YORK TO PROTEST CLIMATE
CHANGE IN SEPTEMBER, AND IT
SUCCEEDED AS AMERICA AND CHINA
SIGNED A CLIMATE ACCORD A FEW
MONTHS LATER.
WOW.
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD, RIGHT?
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I MEAN, MORE POWER TO THESE
FOLKS BECAUSE IF WE DON'T FIGURE
THIS OUT, THEN IT WON'T JUST BE
BLACK PEOPLE SAYING "I CAN'T
BREATHE."
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
OH, TOO SOON?
TOO SOON?
YEAH, I CHOKED HIM, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
AND DON'T FORGET THE
MINIMUM-WAGE PROTEST LAST YEAR.
FAST FOOD WORKERS TOOK TO THE
STREETS DEMANDING A RAISE IN
THEIR PAY...
AND IT WORKED -- THE
MINIMUM-WAGE ROSE IN 21 STATES
TO START THE NEW YEAR, LEAVING
UNDERPAID CHIPOTLE EMPLOYEES
MUCH CLOSER TO ONE DAY BEING
ABLE TO AFFORD CHIPOTLE.
ONE DAY, GUYS, IT'S COMING ONE
DAY.
DON'T TRY TO GET IT ALL AT ONCE.
AND FINALLY, GUYS, THIS IS THE
MOST AMAZING PROTEST OF THEM
ALL, AND I'M NOT MAKING THIS UP.
THE ORGANIZATION "HARRY POTTER
ALLIANCE" WAGED A FIGHT WITH
WARNER BROTHERS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL CHOCOLATE SOLD WITH HARRY
POTTER'S LIKENESS WAS FAIR
TRADE, AND EVEN THAT WORKED!
WHAT?
THAT WORKED!
AND I HAVE TO SAY, AS HAPPY AS I
AM FOR THE
GRYFFINDOR WIN, AFTER FERGUSON
AND GARNER, IT BUGS ME A LITTLE
BIT THAT IN 2014 THIS IS THE
ONLY CHOCOLATE THAT GOT JUSTICE.
(APPLAUSE)
BUT MY POINT IS, IT SUCCEEDED.
SO THEY CAN WORK!
LET'S LOOK AT THE REAL
SITUATION.
MANY CRITICS CALLED THE RECENT
BLACK PROTESTS UNFOCUSED.
I WON'T MENTION ANY NAMES.
(COUGHS)
OPRAH.
SORRY.
I HAD SOMETHING STUCK IN MY
STEDMAN.
NOT CALLING ANYBODY OUT, BUT IN
FAIRNESS IT'S NOT COMPLETELY
INACCURATE.
YOU SEE, IT'S NOT THAT THESE
PROTESTS ARE LESS FOCUSED, IT'S
THAT THE GOALS ARE LESS
TANGIBLE.
IN THE OLD DAYS, IT WAS ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO SIT AT A LUNCH
COUNTER OR GOING TO THE SAME
SCHOOLS OR EVEN VOTING.
TODAY WE'RE JUST TRYING TO NOT
GET SHOT ON OUR WAY TO WORK.
NOW LOOK, I KNOW IT SOUNDS LIKE
I'M EXAGGERATING AND PEOPLE MAY
THINK, "LARRY, CALM DOWN, POLICE
AREN'T TARGETING BLACK GUYS ."
OKAY, ROLL 122.
>> TONIGHT, A SOUTH FLORIDA
FAMILY IS OUTRAGED BY THIS IMAGE
RIGHT HERE AND OTHERS.
THEY SAY NORTH MIAMI BEACH
POLICE USED IT AND THE IMAGES OF
FIVE OTHER MINORITIES AS TARGETS
DURING WEAPONS TRAINING.
>> PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT THERE
SUPPOSED TO BE PROTECTING US ARE
USING US AS TARGET PRACTICE.
>> Larry: THAT STORY WAS
REPORTED WAY BACK IN...
TODAY.
OKAY?
(LAUGHTER)
THE POLICE IN FLORIDA ARE
LITERALLY USING PICTURES OF
YOUNG BLACK MEN AS TARGETS!
HOW CAN WE SEE THAT AND BE
SURPRISED WHEN IT HAPPENS IN
REAL LIFE?
I'M NOT SURPRISED WHEN KOBE HITS
A JUMPER.
THAT DUDE PRACTICES!
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.